[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is be a
subscriber like and comment
hey guys before we start with this video
i just want to thank you all for the
support you've shown to the channel
we are less than 4 000 away from 100 000
subscribers
thank you very much in this video we're
going to talk about jon snow's fate in
the final episode of game of thrones
supportive legend leaks and of course a
few predictions of mine
everyone talks about jon killing dany
and unfortunately that's what we are
going to get and see
danny became the mad queen much to my
disappointment
especially because there was no real
build up for this moment and jon will
had to stop her
what dany just did in episode 5 is what
her father wanted to do before jaime
stopped him
burn everything and everyone down in
king's landing then he did not have any
reason whatsoever to burn down the
capital
the bells rang enemy army surrendered
and all she had to do was march her
armies on the red keep
kill cersei and take the city without
any additional killing
simple as that however dany decided to
unleash firing blood
and kill all the lannister soldiers
including all the innocent people
her armies followed her lead and started
slaughtering all the women and children
except for jon snow who tried to prevent
the battle on the ground
then is after all the mid queen and i
guess the final villain of the story
when the bells rang and when they broke
dany she had her eyes locked on the red
keep
and we all expected dany to go and kill
cersei by burning down the red keep
but now the red key was the last thing
she burned down
she only meant to attack the red kip
after she was done with burning the
entire city
street by street building by building
there's no excuse for any of this
and then he should never have done this
and as much as i like danny she has to
die now
and john knows it perhaps that's why he
was resurrected
to stop danny the mad queen the season 8
finale will start with john davos
centerium walking through the aftermath
of denny's attack on king's landing
leaked plot says they will find greyworm
and his men who have lanes their
soldiers trapped
and they're about to kill them jon tries
to tell grey worm to stop
grayborn tells jon that it's the queen's
order john and tyrion are upset
at some point dany is walking down the
stairs and jon caesar the dragon is
behind her
and looks like she has giant dragon
wings then they cut to dany giving a
speech pretty much saying how she freed
the people from king's landing
and new goal is freeing the rest of the
world then he turns to tyrion and tells
him he committed a treason
tyrion tells her that she killed
thousands of innocent people
and he takes off the hand in spain and
throws it then he sends him to prison
at this point both jon and tyrion
realized varys was right all along
the coin did not land well for this
targaryen queen and tyrion will tell
jean he has got to kill her
it says tyrion tries to convince jon to
turn on dany
his family will never be safe because it
threatens dany's legitimacy
i suppose tyrion will tell jon about
conversation he had with dany
dragonstone
in the beginning of episode 5. the one
about sans signed how dany caesar is a
traitor
and the one plotting to her thrower in
her mind sansa is the reason varys
betrayed her
and she is the reason her claim is
threatened basically tyrion says to jon
to kill dany
not only to save him but to save his
family john is convinced by tyrion that
his family will never be safe
because he represents a threat to her
rule at this point jon's got no choice
but to kill the woman he loves
that's dany's betrayal for love and
that's how this show will end
the show unfortunately made danny the
mad queen and they did it in one single
episode
varys did warn jon he thinks dany is
going mad and jon saw it himself in the
battle of king's landing
tyrion will probably say the same thing
to jon in the next episode
and beside that he will also probably
tell him to stop her
to be fair john already saw for himself
that dany must be stopped
now that she's killed a couple hundreds
of thousands small folk
jon tried to stop his armies from
killing enemy armies
john killed his own man who tried to
force himself on a girl during the
battle of king's landing
how do you think he'll react to the fact
that dany just burned the entire king's
landing
and allowed her armies to brutally slain
women and children
king's landings got a population of 1
million people if not the vast majority
of this number then at least they have
danny just burned alive
john already knows that he's got to stop
danny and tyrion telling him how dany
sees her family especially since that
traders are plotting behind her back
john will only be convinced that he's
got to do it that he's got to stop
danny's madness
no matter the cost no matter the fact
that she's a woman he loves
the leaked plot says jon goes to see her
and she's sitting on the iron throne
alone
and jon tells her that she needs to stop
this madness and that grey worm killed
the lane star's army from the previous
scene
then he tells john that she's doing it
for the people jumper tends to
understand
when her guard is down he stabs her
there was one leaked photo from over a
year ago
where everyone thought it was jon
stabbing dany but by the time all of us
forgot about
it this photo could very well be the
john steps dany scene
costumes fit their current costumes and
the floor seems to be covered in ash
much like the throne room is anyways
after jon kills then it says that
jogging comes and stands over body
and burns the arm throne and carries her
away i don't understand why drogon
doesn't burn jon
yes john is a targaryen but then he was
his mother and john killed her
the league then continues by saying that
jon then surrenders to the unsolid
and grey worm has him and tyrion as his
prisoners demanding justice before he
takes the unsullied and the track and
leaves for essos to fulfill his queen's
last fish
freeing people all over the world from
chains once again white on grave warm
the unsullied or the drakey killjohn
he just killed their queen and they're
putting him on some kind of a trial
unfortunately if you watched my last
video this leak is 100 legit
so i'm not questioning whether it's true
i'm just trying to find logic in all of
this
but then again i might be a fool for
trying because the finale is after all
written by david and dan
so basically instead of killing jon on
sight and raging revenge all over
westeros
dennis armies demand fair trial before
packing up and leaving
i get it they're going back to essos to
do what danny imagined to do with them
before she was killed
but would not they at least seek some
kind of revenge before doing so
anyways greyworm has tyrion and john as
his prisoners
the council led by sansa tells greyworm
to release jon back to them
but he refuses tyrion is in front of the
council
and as the prisoner of grey worm he is
not making decision he is content with
being a prisoner
he makes suggestions only that centurion
says that the new king or queen should
decide what happens to jon
sam suggests a democratic vote for the
new king tyrion calls that idea stupid
the council votes and decides bryce
should be the king bram picks tyrion as
his hand
after this is said and done still cannot
believe bran becomes the king by the
world
the same kid who refused to be lord of
enerfel because time the three eyed
raven now
then they will make a decision about
jon's fate tyrion tells jon that his
punishment is going back to the wall
and joined the night's watch tyrion's
dead grey worm wanted him dead
and sends someone a name back home so
nobody is getting what they want
it's a fair compromise once again no
logic in writing whatsoever
why is there even need for the night's
watch when the world is broken and the
night king defeated
greyworm accepts jon's punishment he
doesn't bend the knee
leaves with his troops and the tracking
on ships to free slave cities
they show tyrion leading the council
before leaving for the wall john has one
last scene with his family
john says goodbye to sansa and arya arya
tells them she is not going back home
she is going to explore whatever is best
of westeros because there is where no
one has been
the final scene is a closing montage you
see arya on a ship
sensor ruling vannerfell and jon go
stormwood and a bunch of wildlings
leaving the wall and heading north
the end of game of thrones what was the
point of the entire the lone wolf dies
but the pack survives slime from season
seven
brands at king's landing sands and
winterfell orioles westeros and jon goes
beyond the wall
all of them now are the lone wolves at
least it says jon leaves the wall and
goes with tormund and goes north
at least jon figures out his punishment
to join the night's watch was dumb
as there's no night's watch nor is there
any need for them
so he leaves it and goes beyond the wall
i also find it ridiculous that bran
would be chosen as the new king
it says that tyrion gives a speech
before brain is voted for a king
so i guess this tyrion speech that makes
everyone vote for brain
but come on would they all really vote
for him if there was any good writing
left
the answer would be no jon might have
killed dany
but that doesn't matter he's their
rightful king for all they know dany
observed the throne
and jon had to kill her to take what's
his by his right
they would all vote for jon snow to be
their king once again i'm not saying the
leak is fake because it definitely is
not
it's legit but the ending is so
ridiculous and disappointing to me that
i cannot get over it
all the high lords are going to arrive
in king's landing during episode 6 from
robin irene to the new prince of dorne
most will come to support jon's claim
varys informed everyone of big imports
that jon is a true heir
they're coming to support him only to
then vote for brain instead of jon to be
the new king
madness madness and stupidity the so
very long evaded bittersweet ending is
jon killing dany
and going to be on the wall while
branstark is democratically chosen as
the new king of the seven kingdoms
is it bitter that jon kills dany or is
it bitter that bran becomes the king
i'm really not sure what exactly is
sweet about this ending
i honestly got no idea i guess it's
going to be nice to see john reuniting
the ghost
and giving him the proper pet he
deserves there you have it guys jon
snow's fate in the game of thrones
finale
at the beginning of an episode jon will
oversee the horrors danny has done to
king's landing
and realize he's got to stop her then
tyrion will reveal to jon how dany sees
his family as traitors
and will likely kill them as soon as she
gets the chance convincing him that he's
got to kill dany
john will then go to the throne room and
kill her after this jon will be
imprisoned
and his fate will be decided by the new
king bran stark
jon's punishment is going to the mall
taking black is what makes him no longer
a legitimate heir to the throne
however that's not where jon will stay
for long as he will only reunite with
tormund and ghost at the wall
and then go with them north beyond the
wall that's how jon's story ends
please let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comment section down
below
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace